first of all happy Monday and I want to
say that I'm gonna start using the word
compelling a little more I'm compelled
to slap your stupid face okay that's
good
I like that and I can sell to buy your
wig that's good too I it's making me mad
but it's good okay you can use it okay
and I can also look at you and just go
you're very compelling well thanks man
now that as a straight man you want to
talk straight man I can't really say
that to you but you could because if I
if I look like but it's suggestive if I
go I have to be honest with you you're
very compelling I mean it's a really
great cop it's a way of saying you're
interesting right yeah like very
interested to a girl though mmm I'd be
well-read you see at the Instagram I'll
see what the [ __ ] correct
that's what I mean it's a sophisticated
word you're compelling and even more so
without your pants mm-hmm
I like that I mean but you couldn't say
your [ __ ] is compelling you could say it
wouldn't be what would be a good word
because when you say your [ __ ] is
compelling it's fine but I want
something even stronger like [ __ ] is
perfect that's always that's nice it's
simple but it's good it's perfect not
too big not too small
hmm okay Ellen it's a compelling story
yeah more this a lot of times it's just
this you got a dick on you well I told
you to Leah loves being around me at the
Comedy Store when dudes come up to me
and those lines they give me like dude
dude you like steak I'm in the middle of
conversation with Julie I go excuse me
is like steak err yeah I guess so man I
like steak yes let's go get a steak
sometime all right absolutely not
thank you though no thank you no thank
you let's go hang let's get a shake man
like smoothies well my when you get to
be a little bit more known and then you
come into town and your mother or
someone says hey I want you to have
dinner with these distant relatives or
your people from high school go let's
come out on my boat III did that's
always confusing cuz I don't really
wanna cuz I don't really who wanna know
I can't give me leave the house your
oh god no it's not happening speaking of
compelling it's really compelling you
missed my surprise birthday party use my
feelings got hurt they should cuz Rogan
said I was at Rogan canceled all his
shows I'm Friday and I was sulky about
it
you didn't come no cuz your girl called
me cap oh no your girl called me and
said hey I'm trying to organize
Brennan's birthday party I'm thinking
about having it March 8th or whatever
wasn't I go [ __ ] I'm gonna be in New
York then you told her you be new and I
said but I may not the problem was I
said let's just move on bro yeah she had
to move on somebody could have [ __ ]
told me she I guess just until you had
town too though yeah she's like I Bryant
can't come yeah Thomas out of town
that's for Emma can I touch I went hey
son of a [ __ ] you missed my surprise
bummed me out man I really wanted to be
assured you missed a fun and you get you
got surprised yeah join of we're driving
cuz she goes hey since you're out of
you're on the road next week and then
your birthday falls on like a Monday or
Tuesday said let's just do dinner
tonight and I was like all right and I
had to stand up she's I just can't just
stand with us to dinner cuz one else
we're gonna do I'm like all right cool
didn't really want to go let's be honest
so I'm like alright then we're driving I
go you know it'd be cool if you you
invited my friends though for my
birthday you know how I always I'm an
[ __ ] yeah I'm a complete [ __ ] and
she goes yeah but also it be cool if
it's just you and me cuz we never get
time right yeah you're right
and so I'm staring off into them my wife
Jen off of this into the [ __ ] either
of the [ __ ] highway and then we pull
up the cap oh you've been a capo and
yeah that's a great great great
restaurant right right no windows but a
great rest amazing Italian restaurants
and as soon as I walk in there's mr. Joe
Rogan Todd Feldman yeah but I would have
been really should be embracing it a hug
I should have [ __ ] a three man way
huh I should have been there
you should have been there I was like I
was like literally like I was pissed
well I looked at Joe and I wasn't you
know I did that Friday night jackdaw not
a [ __ ] with your tears not a [ __ ] day
me coulda made it yeah right meal yeah I
could have made it missed a great meal
with a tray I was in town oh you didn't
know cuz it was your surprise I had no
idea what to do and I knew someone's up
cuz mean Rogan did stand-up on Thursday
together at a show with no lights or
power
with my voice went out so I'm like you
know Rogen were there and I go we're
just chillin waiting for the show start
trying for yeah I go dude work what are
you doing this weekend he is nothing
violent
first at first all right sure bro all
right yeah and I thought how is he being
weird
yeah what the [ __ ] he being so weird
restless guy may just having a bad day
or something like that it was because he
didn't want to give away the surprise my
friend I was born you surprised yeah
like yeah but I should have been there
oh whoa what are you guys doing here it
would have been so much better if I'd
been there hmm
I'm great hey you know what we all
agreed I'm we're glad you weren't there
you are so yeah we all went to three
I've know Brian
I bet no one two three no Brian knows a
good time man yeah but Capitals good two
bright III was mad he missed my father
Saturday
no I asked Joe and I went you know
Brian's in townships no he's not she was
of course it Brian's the first one we
called so she reached out to you I'll
see you Theo
D'Elia where was the Lear in San Diego
on the road Theo was in Boston dude
you're supposed to be in New York Rogan
canceled his shows cuz better friend
than you and then Todd canceled what he
had died I was doing better friend I was
doing 0x it even worse I was free you
could have checked and I and by the way
had no one else to hang out with you was
just
just hanging around man [ __ ] you
three times I again man good thing my
specialists dropping tomorrow
Oh
Oh complicated Apes coming out to you
[ __ ] iTunes or anywhere else you could
call it compelling apes you [ __ ]
[ __ ] maybe to the guy damnit that's a
good title compelling another great
title compelling aids yeah everybody
still wants me to call an American boner
yeah because yes we're awesome my next
special might be no it's not you're too
big of a [ __ ] to ever do the American
boner the American bonus yeah you don't
like views and ratings bro so you want
to collect compelling Apes [ __ ] another
yep that's a cool graphic though yeah
that's Martin Martin made that graphic
nice stud I look like I'm like hey why
am I wearing low first nut that's what
it looks like yeah it does look I get
some Italian boots on um let's see it's
available on and this is tomorrow it's
available right be iTunes itunes google
play demo Australia only in boom oh I'm
an Amazon Prime it'll be on you so it's
available on YouTube yeah but behind a
paywall yeah you sick son of a [ __ ] yep
I don't [ __ ] around you son of a [ __ ]
yep and then Amazon Prime
yep so get it get it only if you like
laughing super hard you only if you want
to bust in your [ __ ] pants yep
only if you want a boss only if you want
a bus cause Brian um so I'm assuming
you're doing media for this yeah I'm
doing media what did you hire our boy
yeah I'm doing a Rob Greenwald yep I
just did a oh [ __ ] I did a podcast
called the kick-ass news podcast
chicken-ass news but you know and I and
I've made a video of him cuz yeah he's
super um he's super like news he and
everything else and then I look at who
he's head-on and he's had on [ __ ]
everybody you can imagine like everybody
from Bryan Cranston to I mean probably
literally I said to my own get trump on
he goes he's the only one I haven't had
on it's a little place in Pasadena they
get like 3 3 million downloads or
something but he's had seriously
everybody like literally everybody ok
a great time so that's the first one I'm
doing I'm doing what the [ __ ] with Marc
Maron well that'd be great I'd be car
trans a huge one
yep Marc's great yep I'll do Rogan and
32 didn't like each other no I like
doesn't mean that I don't know
he did he did an interview I think with
Whitney or so I always you know I love
ya I love mark mark so he's really nice
to me at the store yeah I love mark I've
always liked mark I forget to talk to
him about that on the PSE but you can
tell him I brought it up
because I thought he said I just said
that to him in person why people think
that I don't live we don't know I was
like what the what's going on here I've
always liked mark on mark 420 Walker and
there's there's no better media to do
than our group of friends as far as
podcast is John Rogan shucker uh yeah yo
yep yep I should do all of that about it
for our friends in it Joey Diaz well hey
we got our Santino now I mean all of
those
yeah I'm just mean like you're like you
wanna cast a wide net yeah Santino just
started Rogan Stan Brad Garrett Aaron
Sorkin Jesus Howie Mandel this is the
kick-ass kiss to code this is Lawrence
he's head okay how was he was he cool
guy a grown man yeah yeah
just smart and cool yeah this is the
kick-ass one that Bill Murray yeah he's
had every I'm telling you everyone
everybody that's cool in a stolen big
fancy rylander's yeah what so what all
are you doing tomorrow uh tomorrow's a
lighter day I can't remember I was
supposed to do a an interview with
Forbes magazine online but that makes no
sense
carry on no I know that's the thing like
like like so Grillo is coming out in the
12th page spread in Playboy magazine and
we were talking and it's like a big deal
Grillo or 12 page yeah naked no but I
mean you know they sure does he is the
thing about you know in Playboy
but we were talking with Grillo and I
was we were on ik who actually reads
Playboy anymore it's not you know what I
mean in the 80s didn't even in the 90s
it was a big deal well together
we'll just so you guys know name the
last time so we had a 12 page spread in
a man
Gazoo Magha jall pages dead if it's
really there filling the pages 12:12
yeah I know I know I'm a love Frank
Bassett [ __ ] nobody we were reveal on
must doesn't get twelve pages in there
right we were like that's a really good
point I mean that's a really good point
cuz playboys I don't think anyone's
reading it have a better body Frank I
know no but that is interesting like if
you I mean playboy from me my generation
and even partially your generation was a
an American mainstay yeah hold on no
one's reading it for comedy or what
Frank grills doings career I'm actually
about Jack and I remember Playboy
magazine dope back in the day was always
known for its amazing interviews back in
the day mm-hmm but then hustler came out
went hold my beer check out these
[ __ ] went oh and then playboy kind
of skated round
yeah and always had that sort of like if
you were a Playboy centerfold that was a
big deal right yeah in 1997 correct but
then now it's remember playboy went you
know what we're not gonna show women
anymore naked women and their stock went
yeah and they're like you know what
we're gonna bring back the women let's
do that bring back to where you got it
man cause I'm a a Halsey whoo I'm a fan
that'd be an understatement yeah I'm a
fan fan yeah you have at least to kill
it man yeah it's tough if you're in
print media [ __ ] you one glass sent me
but like a mom at the airport I'll
scroll to Jesus Christ I'll scroll
through the magazines yeah other than
that went I mean besides books and even
then you get them on your [ __ ]
tablets and yep so okay so you did an
interview Playboy yeah you're me making
a parents at Blockbuster what else you
doing yeah so I mean I'm doing a bunch
of stuff I've got a bunch of stuff lined
up I'm gonna probably end up doing foul
on those for those those different talk
shows eventually again how much then
move the needle when it comes to buying
product will see only a foul and be
baked for you yeah yeah do some stand-up
on there so I submitted tape they all
they all know me and they all like me so
we'll see I hear good things mother you
know you know what it is hopefully but
yeah but needed
happen soon right right away why I guess
but I'll show you the special is gonna
be out so it's on demand so yeah it's
all good yeah what I'm gonna do also
blow your release one release never grow
up just like clips of it so that people
and then with like with a link to the
other that's confusing so let me let's
just talk about that yeah let's release
your old special that no one's seen and
everyone is funny though for sure but
then they assume that's your newest one
ah because I'll have I'll have I'll have
a thing that says see the newest one
like a you know Martin and figure it out
I'm not worried about it all I want to
put it on how I see be I want to put her
on it anyway because I will but I would
wait B I would because I would release
clips of your new one oh honey I'm doing
that to 100% oh I see you're saying I'm
already doing that that's already
happening yeah yeah but I want to put I
want to put my whole special the old one
on I would do that after this boom of
your news yeah yes otherwise it's very
compared it's confusing for me and I'm
right I don't say it yeah yeah I see
what you're saying
if you if you throw all of it I hear the
plan is not they would never do that
the plan is first do this and then then
I'm gonna eventually release never wrong
so what I'm saying is that over the
course of the time when you have any
time you watch never grow up like later
on you'll have a link to the new special
yes I'm saying yeah but yeah to new it's
a new frontier it's all changing so
[ __ ] quickly yes it really is and
that's our Maxim yeah yeah damn that's
pretty cool as max I'm still doing it
I don't know these are all good
questions these are all good questions
did Brian read his own did I read that
article I didn't I didn't read that I I
just realized that I never even read
that article yeah so there's that I have
no idea what it says could be like this
guy's a big mouse who does read their
own articles for god sakes people do
right that's weird
not me you know I don't even watch my
own show not yet beware - yeah that's
yeah they're still doing it though that
what they were my face
hey we're a great magazine yeah I know
it's just magazines are [ __ ] weird
we just look at everything online now
yeah why would you I can have it because
you can I can have it now correct
Instagram you want to see making women
just go to the Internet yeah great ass
you're not the best page either is it
okay god damn Maxim skates if you've got
to him deal up no Hey look at rathaus
Hey look a skinny white girl Hey look a
Ferrari
exactly God did you ever rob report that
magazine
you remember that like oh I do all the
expensive yes yes I renewed like that
they'd have dogs you could buy a
executive privilege dogs offense you
could buy many horses you could buy
plain dude you know what at a hotel in
New York when I was there last year for
Showtime that was in the room they had
robbed reports and they had hold that
car magazine yeah where do you buy like
for all they've got all that you know
see this shit's robbed reports still
killing it look at their cool [ __ ] oh
yeah that thing's worth that that cars
worth 1.3 million dollars I think it was
an old rusty car just sitting there
[ __ ] nuts
Rob report old-school then I know isn't
that crazy he's crazy man it's crazy so
ya bunch of press tomorrow dude yeah
tomorrow and Wednesday dude look how
shiny my nails are dude I got a pen
Keith Thurman you and Keith Thurman had
a pedicure so original plan was do a
pedicure yeah this is a manicure I'd
rather a manicure I don't like my feet
[ __ ] with I've like ingrown toenail
right now I hike all day Estates my
toenails flared up so I thought oh good
a pedicures gonna be dope to be I'll
take care of this you know and they
don't speak English there's no judgment
I'll really give a [ __ ] of the talk [ __ ]
and Asian or whatever yeah Chinese
Chinese probably Korean or no this one
specific said Chinese okay so hold your
judgment okay as long as you don't I
made that up you know you're probably
Korean yeah I don't wanna be judged hey
um so I want to get my feet done but
Keith went cool no one touches my
[ __ ] feet
no doubt I hear you man I don't want
touching my feet either and so he's
awesome we had better yeah he's great
he's really good yeah just Chatty Cathy
a Chatty Cathy chatty chatty Kathy
really good dude where did you guys talk
about why was he out he had an injury to
his shoulder or what was it oh yeah it
to tears if he just fought though two
months ago with her when his fight now
he's waiting for you see what happens
with Mikey Garcia and Earl Spencer jr.
this weekend I'm excited he might get
the pack y'all got good money on Earl
Spence he's just too big for my humans
everybody yeah too big for Mikey they're
shiny they look very shiny to my tongue
no no no I don't I don't like it but
also Keith nails were long dude really
yeah his were sniff cocaine what's he do
I don't know his word his were nice
mm-hmm
mine cuz I buy them dude I went on a
hike yesterday yeah
Chinn shown this picture I was gonna say
you hike huh I love my [ __ ]
where I never even see you know where I
live
yeah all around there's some great
hiking oh yeah don't tell me about it
you don't know [ __ ]
I know hiking or I'll click on the how
about my wife saw that and my wife goes
I like that truck I was like what um not
for you Amanda I keep going no that's
all right look at this look at this
looks like the window saver no keep
going chin forward heap forward for [ __ ]
sakes look at that back look at their
sons is that a windows right up
screensaver yeah look at that man that's
amazing
that out here Topanga where's that four
miles from the house for mouth yeah not
so nice things I like about it now the
trip was a little far and the family is
not ready for it I was but we had to
ration the chips and the water because I
thought we were gonna be in some trouble
yeah instead going right I went left
because the the the signs of they paint
got washed out cuz the storms so we went
left get a little dicey there at the end
I see son fell asleep had to carry him
so you have a 45 pound weight oh boy he
says roughly your size we're about the
same size he's 6 1 @ 4 years 3 years old
so [ __ ] cute I'm sure her stupid cute
great little jawline he's so gay dude he
looks different that I remember like
that picture you sent me I'm seeing him
since he was 2 months old
you saw him oh wow you never had me over
so we don't hang out with my birthday
party dude it's unbelievable man that's
a great picture you were here miss Mike
goddamn that they forgot he's out he's
asleep he's dressed the exact same as
Rogan was at the improv
rody has that same tracksuit I know and
when I saw my Center well alright you
look like a Russian [ __ ] like your
member Russian keeps like he's part of
cubes yes I'm Tim yes yeah he's gonna be
he's probably gonna be quite the athlete
who knows man
but that out there's gorgeous man yeah
amazing out there I love it out there I
find out exactly where it is and go out
there yeah well well that's it for us
man that's good if I just walk well
let's go tell you how was the the
Commerce draw Tite a Sunday night I told
you I don't work on Sundays again
that's the Lord's Day I know that's the
Lord's Day but still packed their
clothes tonight that's that it's always
packed though the main room that's I've
never been there it's not grand they
were rowdy and they were loving it and I
think a lot of people are from in from
out of town but they were awesome
yeah they were awesome it was crazy how
about my daughter running on the air
assault my air Raul you cannot look any
older below that the UM sorry sir hey my
what happened there's a face a lot
well no but dude you look young well
that's because of my eyes it's my eyes
dude no bro bro yeah look you see how my
eyes are falling once I get them look I
can have that skin removed I'm gonna do
it and I'm gonna be good looking but um
are you gonna do that evening my mother
said I should do it because what happens
is with her and me our eyes like she got
it done you can't tell well what
happened to your mom is done yeah the
skin fall you have to do it once in your
life there's like some guy named dan
Baker some [ __ ] yeah there's a million
guys who do it yeah but I mean that's my
eyes I got to make sure I do
I've been nude and best place for cut
for plastic surgery in the world yeah
but do you know then again I can always
tell when people have plastic surgery I
don't wanna I'm not gonna be the guy
who's like he had his eyes done at 52
that's embarrassing your eyes done we're
not worried but I don't want to know it
as I talked about I'm here but what are
you gonna do just they
your bloodhound yeah yeah that's the bra
okay they take my thumb be sure you like
a shar-pei yeah they take this skin okay
oh my god
they take the skin and whether they
think you know John Travolta and how
tight his face is now oh my gosh dude
Bera Singh don't do that to your Li
think he is oh let me see that let me
see what they're gonna do to is that
here severe eyelid pierre using front
towles sling have that guy - what's
wrong with this Asian dudes eyes the
Haitians wait he's young he's probably a
I'm sorry Matt did he not eat where his
eyes not Beijing he might be mixed I
wouldn't assume that use maybe but no
look at amis though you can close this
eye up wait that's what you want to get
done or you want to snip a couple of
wrinkles off the top yeah you just take
some of the skin off and apparently it's
a very very what did you go do chin wait
yeah I don't have droopy eyes why'd you
go droopy eyelid surgery eyelid excess
skin surgery oh that isn't exist skin
right yeah let's go get older my eyes
have changed I don't you know dudes like
that right
that lady looks exactly the same yes
yeah looks I'd ever be the same does she
that's right something like that exactly
like that
that's what you only get done yeah what
a waste of time you just wanna get rid
of the hanging skin um yeah yeah I'd you
have trouble with your vision my mother
said that I will eventually like achieve
she was it was like she showed me
pictures of her and I went oh [ __ ] and
then she goes look at my eyes now and
you can't tell and I was like God why
wouldn't I do that because it distracts
me because one is drooping lower so on
camera it looks lopsided I don't like it
now I I can't believe I'm even talking
about getting plastic surgery on my face
which I just killed I know all guys who
do then I'm for sure you know roast the
[ __ ] just do a nose job though well
you at it while you're under while your
new Kenny Loggins are not kenny loggins
kenny rogers before and after we check
the space and jetsam work oh ho what
Kenny Rogers this is food Larry I don't
hate I hate on anyone who gets my
surgery I just want you to touch it ooh
look at his eyes look at that come on
dude don't get your whole face tightened
you look like him you just come on I
mean yeah yeah you got some teeth on him
though Johnny that's some chopped Chaves
you get your teeth too white you can't
do that just just get old all good and
then just do you all know wants to snip
the nut sacks off your eyelids yeah you
just gotta be careful with when you go
to see the cheek fillers that's where it
gets a little dicey right just your eyes
bro wax that can see that and the eyes
even the eyes are a little bit of a
telltale sign too though don't get crazy
with the ass dude do you think Kenny
Rogers [ __ ] all the girls in the land
I think he I don't know I know he was
there he could sing his ass off what's
his most famous song the gambler maybe
looked chin do you know him I feel like
you would realize yeah I liked his newer
stuff oh man
Wayne Blaney boy he know she went he did
so much like surgery he went from white
dude Asian he's out he got his face
tucked so far back what does he do
they're like you know you're gonna look
like a mix Korean kid right he went just
[ __ ] do it
what is he doing uh-oh hold on just hold
that there hold out there dude what show
- show business a [ __ ] you don't
know that you look ridiculous though you
don't know that you look no did he turn
in an old Asian man how does his how
does his doctor how do you how do you
not know that you look absolutely
unacceptable well but yeah but on the
left you don't think no one told me look
like the Red Baron from the pizza
commercial what you got it gold you got
to just be like this is who I am
not that [ __ ] guy have you seen
Mickey Rourke oh I watch that doctor
losers he was on there that doesn't
count
Oh zero bleak changes he wears a wig the
whole thing's a disaster like I that
poor man
that's that to me that's mental to me is
more than that's that's more than vanity
ladies know right at something Ricky or
Mickey Rourke has mental sickness I
think he's just in show business see
Mickey Rourke's not trying to look young
but look at his shirt another monster on
- but look at him look at how beautiful
he was when he was younger look at that
[ __ ] now that's a wig dude what the [ __ ]
is going on dude
how about that what if they're not a
doctor either goes Brown I don't think
we should do this that's what I'm saying
isn't there a doctor who goes look you
look like a mask you look like a
Halloween dude you look like a monster
I mean what the [ __ ] is going on [ __ ] is
that in there oh is that fake it's real
that's him
no that's fake that's fake I think
that's real that's real come on jeez I
think that's more of a mental sickness
that [ __ ] great Danny scary I'm
using great and uh [ __ ] iron rain
three oh he's fantastic but as a monster
he's great but what the [ __ ] there what
is going on like he was III I don't know
- mental sickness bro it is it is it's
mental sickness that's a wig you're
wearing a wig sir when I think of
Hollywood that's what I think about not
me the last thing I think about really
yeah [ __ ] no he's that he's the hell no
I'm gonna he's the exception me I'm
gonna have to find out his doctors and
avoid him yeah I want to go to that
doctor for your eyes he wake up looking
like that dude I mean yeah he was a
handsome dude before oh he was the best
Stallone said that there was no one who
got women like that David Blaine used to
hang out with him David Blaine tell me
it's like that bad dude was in other
news no [ __ ] fellas but the other thing
you know I you know I can't get enough
of you know my favorite show on TV
you guys can roast me American Idol the
early stage of American Idol show man in
the stories do you watch a chin they
used 200 fish this year most talent ever
really and there's like in the it's
weird cuz the talent comes from people
who they have no idea that they're good
and even you'd like to have no idea like
this one kids like super shy just as
like street performances and he comes in
and they say it's the best audition
they've ever had on American Idol and
he's so good and the line of Ritchie
goes do you realize how talented you are
and the kids like uh he goes you can
play the piano can't you guys yeah and
you just go play the piano and just his
own song that he wrote you hold up you
wrote that is yeah it's original song
let me can we see that is that we gonna
watch it with to edit it out most likely
to a nineteen best American Idol
audition it's crazy though man it's nuts
and but when they talk about the stories
or they're there's one kid there too
there is tough one
yep that guy that that guy the awkward
kid so he wrote this song
alejandra it's weird cause use real shy
coming in can play the guitar
Wow wrote this song by the way
[Music]
who's that guy
country singer I am the world loop riot
he's a stud I love him so you're the
student I love his face oh this guy's a
killer no I think you'll get on the
piano a lot killer the girl shy he is
he's awkward awkward hug you are so
talented I am so inspired Thanks now I
just feel like I'm in the presence of
greatness
I am so glad cheesy were here oh it was
like watching my favorite movie Katy
Perry's speeches I think you're an
absolute genius
thank you I don't even want to say
anybody anything
don't know it makes it even she has no
idea there's nothing like you my friend
I will not sleep Wow
then he plays the piano what a [ __ ]
harvest lark what an artist but there's
been like three like that there's
another there's a redhead who was really
good there was this girl this like it
kind of fat girl I Kandra I don't know
this him this one they asked him to play
piano Oh another song
[Music]
I can play them yeah man I'll see the
vocal sound terrible secondhand right
now yeah it's the way it's recorded this
way down he's freaking naturally just a
real talent gasping crazy man then
there's a guy last night a bit a big fat
guy and he's just so fat and then yeah
but you don't think he's gonna be any
good and he plays and they're like what
the [ __ ] there's some bad man he talked
about how he's like beat up by his dad
and all this time horrible and then
there was a redhead there's oh so that
let's see oh my god dude play the blind
contestant she's blind as she was she
was unborn say she's mine his father
they cheat they she has a tumor behind I
went blind
she got bullied at school and then she
comes to seeing this dude sometimes
American I'll make you cry man oh yeah
stories it makes you cry hard god I love
it this real talented guy they go they
go what do you do he goes I'm in sales
and he's like knocks the performance out
like super talented and Katy Perry goes
what do you do you know you do you know
how good you are and he goes mmm
she was what do you know yes I know I
probably should be in sales like I
should be doing this I shouldn't be in
sales but I don't know how good I am
she's like well here's you're going to
take it you're [ __ ] good Wow it's
pretty cool I'll play this blind girl
then we'll move on she's blind his [ __ ]
had a tumor then went blind gets bullied
at school pretty girl to get glasses now
I went to dr. karts office and she had
done a bunch of tests on my eyes she
came back and she's like you need to go
to the ER now
once I got back into school that was the
bad part the kids were like so cool
that's they called me names they would
kick my cane I don't believe it pushed
me really I feel like they told me to
say that I asked not a chance I was like
why did that happen to me
I hope not yeah Brian cuz she's acting
really supportive and [ __ ] with duty
high school kids when they tell these
stories I'm I can't see bro know when
they when they tell these stories it's
like please be able to turn please be
good to get ready this is a great show
for this reason that shit's amazing to
me oh alright when she said that went
off [ __ ] good get ready good you're
ready cuz she bombs just kidding ha ha
just kidding she's a Lionel Richie crime
are the wrinkles over your eyes filling
up what a perfect song for she's I
finally made the [ __ ] cold hearted
old man cry god man
something is she good yeah she'd sing to
God brother you need to watch my long
flight 17 and sing that song come on man
look they're all crying - come on dude
I'm a cyborg event that got me your
sociopath image alright what a good guy
he is by the way she never thought about
audition for American Idol know some of
those people like that Alejandro guy and
there's another guy on there who's like
they're kind of there their styles
different I don't think granted now
everyone knows their name and I feel
like America now is not the platform for
them like I don't think they're gonna do
that well with the pop culture songs all
that but they're so creative this like
the Alejandro who's on the guitar
alright it's not really gonna cross over
it's it's a faux key right but well no
he's like so unique we're covering
people's songs when he's a right or
right and like he's so original art
imitating these other artists oh you
don't have those pipes that I know like
yeah he's not he's not gonna be the
pop-culture star that American Idol
makes everywhere you know ruin I don't
say ruin I think the delay is growth so
um so I'm thinking because I what I was
telling my girls like man if if I'm like
a owner like executive at Sony or
somewhere I would watch angle all right
let's get this kid off my case I'm right
now developmental deal figure it out
but he's a songwriter here's the thing
though as soon as you show ears on
American Idol the contract you signed
says you don't they own they own it so
I'm strong he can't get out
yeah I wonder if they could always how
would you get discovered like on the
other side that American I was like you
won't even know who [ __ ] Alejandro
was if it wasn't for extra man we're
talking about him yeah I know so you
know and also you know he can make that
money live when he goes off and the
you know anywhere no we can't okay no no
that's the thing a lot of people like
Kelly Clarkson like that's really you
don't really a lot of them don't go back
to American Idol cuz they're like the
contract [ __ ] me it's kinda like the
Ultimate Fighter like Ellen I was like
well we made you it's like I know is
your what you got me under the shitty
contract
what was your contract cuz ever when you
signed your new contract with Dana yeah
different but so it's a minimum and it's
like over a long time so for these guys
like so the top 10 go on a tour
you can't venture off on your own and do
shows you can only perform under that
banner
mm-hm they're just covering their ass so
you know you're not gonna blow up else I
remember I was gonna sign a deal with
[ __ ] it might have been it might have
been ear of someone like that back in
like the 90s it was or maybe even MTV or
something and they used to have things
where where you'd sign a deal where they
owned anything you did in pepper to
perpetuity so forever
Jesus says so in other words whatever
you did they always home like 50 percent
of what this contract I was I did not
[ __ ] out of here that didn't stand up in
court you got it you got chance I'm tell
you though American I always watch
especially either out as it goes arm I
don't I can't fall off but early on
before these kids know how good they're
it's so good yeah and they used to
always kind of make fun of the like the
real shitty people which they don't
anymore they just did show you thank
talent would you think god I don't like
scene sometimes a really shitty ones
especially if they're cocky hilarious
but when they're like hoping to do good
and they don't it's a bummer yeah they
used to bring that on but what something
about somebody who's blind
that makes me or Daffy or or you ever
meet somebody with a speech and all on
deficits on this though I'm sorry
no you said deaf American Idol don't not
familiar with them how they do pop then
I'm sorry no no no no what famous
composer went deaf
yep what famous composer Mozart no gone
that's the only one I know Beethoven ah
[ __ ] yeah
I'm sorry and I almost said no I'm
talking about dancers happy here the
music
oh no there was a deaf dancer really
beat [ __ ] Paige Vanzant and dance
with the Stars oh yeah you don't say
yeah
you just have to leaders oh the
vibrations of the music then you can
dance oh yeah you should feel I feel I
feel the rhythm feel the rhythm of the
night the rhythm of the night I think
that was say you just gotta feel the
dance in your body move
dad says yeah she got step to the left
you know yeah I'm gonna start taking
some dance yeah mute seniors oh that's
cool I feel like well I'm gonna get into
music India Merc you know I love it
though man so yeah some of the stories
that tell you I just cried I've never
seen you cry that was a little
embarrassing yeah I can't handle it you
can't sing that song tell me that's this
team and when she said she was getting
bullied as soon as I hear the bad
stories I'm like please be able to sing
please don't [ __ ] on it
who would bully what do not go to high
school go to med even high school no cut
nobody hits or [ __ ] that's what I say
like well like go on it well you don't
read comments what's rerai recombinase
she was a boy before
Yeah right but if you go to instagram
like if you like if you post a picture
of cat and said something beautiful
right like solid say she got engaged on
that people would go on and say the
worst things possible it's like it's
just crazy to me yeah or like you know
my cousin or my niece who passed away
they were saying I was acquitted was she
popular in school that like she got
bullied I'm like for what yeah like kiss
she was a white girl with a booty I'm
like the [ __ ] of celebrated when I was
in high school yeah like yeah but the
way they pick on her yeah what the [ __ ]
is happening
police believe bullies it's so bad this
damage I know it is my son deals with it
right now but it's like who bullies a
blanket but also the parents like
hopefully I can dedicate my son where
it's like you if you see the wind you
push that that's right you protect you
shut that [ __ ] down that's right I'd
rather you get suspended for whooping
their ass for bullying oline friend
Albright
O'Brien's to do that I used to [ __ ]
do that I would I feel like bullying
when I was a kid especially when you
were the kid when you guys were playing
with rocks and sticks when when when I
was a kid when I was a kid [ __ ]
well you're being a serious agent when I
was a kid though it's like they've they
roast you in your shoes or like if you
had a busted face so I'm like that but
it wasn't relentless and then once you
stuck up for yourself like fought it was
over I never got bullied but I did have
mmm but a bunch of my friends who were
football players they got no they they
did a friend my friends was a little
heavy she was heavy if a friend yep
and I found out that they were making
fun of her she went off crying and old
Bry why were they making fun of her
though cuz she was fat and just because
she was fatter she what you don't want
us to get old Bry who's the nice guy you
don't want to get me you don't start
that key no because I'll fight everybody
wanna rev up this old old dudes
Oldsmobile because you want to rev all
the skinny meek and we'll take out some
eyes and [ __ ] some people up and I don't
kow tough you are as I get right yeah
your son the boys off when I feel
righteous I come at you and I went out
at that table and I said I said now I'm
gonna [ __ ] now I said I'm how I said
you know I know your lines improve I
said who wants to die yeah he's the
entire table football players just don't
believe your story the entire table went
your right bride my bad yep no it's not
fake came out beautiful I went and I
[ __ ] kicked them in their faces yeah
I gave him I gave each one of my face
kicked yep no Isis not hear you but did
that yeah there should be ice not just
Kim's it's so strange to me kids even
put up with it like I never like you've
allowed it like you imagine like today
we're in this office and some dude some
blindly walked by him to do it both
blind I'd like what the [ __ ] just say
who would do that if you did that around
me I would punch you and the whole thing
the kids realize Sochi in high school
middle school they don't realize like
what kind of dramatic impact that has on
people dude I was in New York and a guy
who's get out of my way you all bag this
guy you said that - you know - this old
late ball
I was like man I got so mad I was in
Italy who old dad it to his lady yo bag
and I [ __ ] I saw red and I start and
he was crazy it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] it
wasn't crazy he was an [ __ ] now he
was an [ __ ] it was in New York he was
a New York [ __ ] there's a lot of so
ask what what what Albrighton [ __ ]
what old bride did you want me to tell
you yeah nothing good
you moved on and got a year sure didn't
and then told me called me said I just
yes but Friday got behind him and
started catcalling no kitty kitty kitty
kitty
turn around with the mirror like that I
kept doing that I followed them all the
way to the subway mm-hmm just to kind of
make them feel uncomfortable here God
we're technique Wow you're technique
when you get caught when you start being
sexualized by dude behind you it's a
problem what if he's gay like hell yeah
it's a good day you see that old [ __ ]
over there let's do this bro hey I got a
story for you I'm on my way to acting
class I'm 22 or 23 and I just my dick
was a little hard I was I had been on
the subway thinking about having sex
with some girl yeah yeah so I got up and
I had a little bit of tough get still
had out a little bit about yeah boner I
was just I was rearing I was rearing and
I'm walking took up in your walk and and
I hear this giant very gay black guy
swear to God go he walked by me and he
goes oh he goes oh he got a hug himself
he goes oh he got a heart and he turned
back around it started walking on he was
walking like farther away on the divider
I walk and he kept looking at me and
trying to get in front of me hey wonder
you feel that bozo oh my boner went
right back do I bet you felt much bigger
than me feel weird and he was right I
had a little bit of a IKEA walk the
streets in New York with my [ __ ] it out
bro
I tried bro he was like I'm your breathe
free let me I know let him do the
[ __ ] but he wasn't fully you the Loch
Ness monster are you sure he was bent
down but he was just he was bent and he
was bald yeah the gonzo nose that's
right because
I was God's are nosing yeah that's
exactly I was doing I was gonzo nosing
it's called the concert yeah I'd like to
tuck it up myself man yeah dude I was
thinking of you because I watch this
document you could have hard-ons
speaking of you gonna jack off when you
get home to this I was watching this
Netflix docked doc called transformer
yeah it's about this professional power
lifter this dude who's in the military
went with three kids amazing dad now mom
went you know what I feel like a woman
all my life and turned and had the
transition to a woman yeah come at me
Caitlyn Jenner come at me bright I'm
sorry can you say that again
yeah bodybuilder marine power lift yeah
wait you know what feel like a woman now
even though I'm in my 40s no now I'm
gonna start being a woman what
toss the wig on now you can stop taking
TRT now hey hey just feel me out here is
that not your style look yeah hey in
like when I saw it Brian be into this
let's say didn't she didn't have a dick
would you be into it like you love real
muscular guys girls I mean that's that's
simply too much for me also this is very
confusing because you spend a lot of
time taking testosterone nope that's
androids they ask they bring this up
yeah the guy goes there is that's what
he used to look like yeah and that's all
natural but what we said no he talks
like he did steroids yeah yeah yeah yeah
and the guy goes so you feel taken like
peds and he goes she goes no I stopped
taking testosterone I'll never take it
again on estrogen now uh-huh okay
so I consider this to be a form of
mental illness not just oh that's gonna
hurt her feelings because someone says
that on there that's not fair dude but
that's he pioneered more you're more
educated than that to say that dude but
look because because she was she talks
about that how her entire life she felt
this way just gonna do okay but so that
her entire life fell away and went the
opposite direction now she's going this
way you have to admit it's very
confusing Italy not really would you say
that she's a little confused in her hell
okay no I just like to me I'm like I if
that's what you wanna do [ __ ] do it I
don't think it's meant to that's not my
point I'm saying I would have to say
that there's some mental illness there
really think that's fair to say
oh well but sometimes our wiring here
sometimes your wiring self yeah
wirings off you just said it did but
that doesn't mean mental illness why
don't know how to define mental illness
look at the end of the day IIIi don't
it's it's it's interesting to me I'm I'm
looking at a coin wow that's fascinating
okay what's really going on there like
you maybe maybe he felt like a woman
he says he went the opposite face yeah
that's right masking it so I'm the
complete opposite but he also goes she
goes I also like I love lifting yeah uh
how's this I don't know what to say
about any of it it's pretty interesting
I'm glad you brought it up I don't give
up I'm actually fascinated yeah I don't
know I don't say it's mentally ill I
don't smell things I think there are
some people's mental illness incorrect
but in some cases i if they're wiring is
different I mean that's it's that's a
giant man they're right with a wig on
alright you know I'm saying like that
that's well the body yeah but the inside
she feels like a woman sure sure who
gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah and she also
deadlift the [ __ ] out of you you know by
the way what does that even mean right
inside I feel like a woman inside I feel
like a man well me I don't know maybe
it's I want to be pretty I don't I don't
I don't know yeah you're off on this so
like John I'm not off on it because I'm
not sure what the [ __ ] but if but if he
says I felt like a what so he says in
high school when he's playing football
you know when they wear the jerseys to
school like every Friday the football
players wear jerseys and the Chili's
weird the Chilean outfit he always one
being the cheerleading outfit he was
pissed he can be entirely outfit all
right all right cool you still think
mental illness I think that that's a
candidate I don't think so I think I
think with some there are I think some
people's wirings just a few yeah I
definitely think that to like you're 15
I am jazz no no I agree and I I'm not
saying that's not the case I'm saying
sometimes sometimes it can also be a
case of whatever you want to call think
that's the exceptional illness there's a
lot of different kinds of mental illness
so
careful with that yeah Abel cuz I'm not
an expert on mental illness well you're
not but I do think that this is really
strange to me because I think this
person is still taking male hormones no
bro you got to watch it be to talk to
how he's not anymore okay but can you
you know I hear in that and I know you
know better but you can't you just want
to be feminine right she had her face
done - taking estrogen yeah and she
talked about the a-string but if you
take testosterone estrogen you can't
have a pink ball right the counter each
other okay so you getting you getting
nothing yeah go back to Mark Wahlberg
yeah i don't know i don't know i've i
think that that's a case for deep
confusion I would say that deeply
confused you know I don't know I don't
know those traps are natural nice
captain strong - well that's awake
obviously authorities say it's a week
you know what it is I wonder how one
what are you trying to accomplish feel
like more like a woman yet you're taking
you're still probably taking even though
she says she's not I think she's still
take but these are old pictures be huh
don't go to her Instagram chin see what
she looks like now so I'm not sure when
they feel that documentary yeah great
dad though or mom got kids yep three of
them and the kids were pretty dope about
it - well yeah I mean everybody's got
their thing man
what's her name Danielle barber jew
named marie crock Janee Marie
yeah
they did because she's had work done
this is the most recent okay
you said I'm saying this by some
confusion in her brain - about what
you're taking and me that's all those
are kids [ __ ] know that mom has a
tattoo on her throat okay
duh just get out of here chin so you can
see the whole page let's go down yeah
maybe there yeah sometimes you want to
be both there sometimes you just want to
whoa who's that
that's her you [ __ ] yeah might be
photoshopped all right how into that
picture either
who's that no I know you're gay that's
how Brian oh we're really gonna
transgenders Pidgey oh wow who's that
well that's the profile of the male
bodybuilder who's now a woman you gave
buck now that there's a problem of that
and I don't hear and you're not mentally
sick turn your turn bad right away your
coffee you're like the biggest homophobe
toward me you're gay you're gay [ __ ]
yeah I don't care that you are but you
who's that that's exactly big chick with
long hair yeah bro
it's an interesting documentary
regardless that there's a back on you
that's when he's competing bro
yeah all right out there with that data
documentaries interesting and then the
Michael how about the Michael Jackson
one they thought it was gonna be like
the are Kelly one yeah we're like
changed lives but when you do the
research on the two guys who are in that
documentary and you look at the
documentary how they didn't they want to
interview anyone else who would give a
counter-argument to what they're doing
they wanted to paint that narrative so
they only interviewed people who they
knew were gonna paint that narrative
yeah so it shits on Michael Jackson when
you look into it some those guys are
shady very shady especially especially
the main ones so so so I haven't seen
the documentary but I do agree that any
guy who's spending 30 days with a kid
and his and you see this LaToya Jackson
1993 came out and said did you see that
no okay so we'll look that up wait hold
on
Toya Jackson said in 1993
my brother has to stop with these little
innocent children ah like hanging out oh
look at this watch this
this is the weekend edition where we
take a look at this week's hottest
stories and first there are even more
revelations about Michael Jackson this
week the Jackson family stood divided
has the comments about Michael Jackson
continued Latoya who has long been
estranged from the family accused her
brother Michael of crimes against small
children on Wednesday at a midnight
press conference in the Israeli city of
Tel Aviv where she was on a tour that
suffering from poor attendance and
emotionally charged Latoya had this to
say I must tell you that um this is very
difficult for me but Michael is my
brother I love him a great deal but I
cannot and I will not be a silent
collaborator of his crimes against small
innocent children and if I remain silent
then I means that I felt the guilt of
the humiliation that these children are
feeling and I think it's very wrong I
have seen checks payable to the parents
of these children Wow and I don't know
that these children were apparently
brought the parents by Michael or not
but I had seen these texts and I've seen
these checks through my mother she
showed me these checks but Michael had
written to these children and it's for a
great amount and I'm not speaking
pennies the sums are very very large
amount and this is my first time talking
what does she look like Michael Jackson
I know nothing but I think it's bad
because I am a bit too myself and I know
what it feels like and these kids are
gonna be scarred for the rest of their
life and I don't want to see any more
innocent small children being affected
this way I love Michael very dearly but
I feel even more sorry for these
children because they don't have a life
anymore they don't now you stop and you
think for one second and you tell me
what 35 year-old man it's gonna take a
little boy and stay with him for 30 days
and take another boy and stay with him
for five days in a room and never leave
the room how many of you out there are
35 years old how many men are out there
there you go he would take little kids
and do that there you go I have respect
for her
I don't want it maybe hurt I've been
hurt by it too my father molested me
sexually and I don't like it I don't
want way too hot dad Jackson dad is a
piece of [ __ ] looks identical to our
brother the one molestation does too
why do you think she did that to her
face this is very common for people
who's Ellard mala station 100% male
shows sexual molestation causes such
damage and people who suffer from it
later on in their life do things like
[ __ ] with their face and stuff only eat
it leave - I'm trying you surgery on
your eyes Wow listen I was going bad on
these guys for not defending Michael
Jackson and my wife said something to me
that I think it's worth like she goes
out on who I was going back on the guys
who didn't defend who didn't who
defended Michael Jackson these two guys
when they took the stand remember I was
saying they had a chance to put up if
this is true they had a chance to put a
child molester behind bars but they
defended him in remember yeah so she
goes like this she goes when talking
about the two men in defendant Michael
Jackson in their 20s I think it would be
wise to remember that no 20-year old man
wants to face a future having been
sexually molested active with the King
of Pop imagine that girls won't
sometimes girls wouldn't want anything
to do with them in their mind in your
early 20s you have a very micro view of
the world the macro view comes later
with age and perspective justice okay
[ __ ] right about she's right hold my
beer so here's the thing yeah so yeah
I'm sure they don't want to get any of
that so how about several years later
he's back in court for child molestation
yeah Michael didn't reach out to that
guide to defend him he comes out and
defend him Mike is like all right cool
I'm not sure why he's doing this comes
back out why is he come back out well
his career is unraveling he's not famous
anymore needs money boy goes to the jack
and this is current yeah then goes to
the Jacksons goes hey I know you're
doing that thing in Vegas
remember Michael Jackson whoa I won't be
the choreographer for that and the
Jackson family goes no we have someone
else heals what the [ __ ] fine I'm gonna
come out with a tell-all book they
molested me like what or give me this
money they go well know try sell the
book doesn't get picked up oh all right
try selling the book doesn't get picked
up then goes all right we're gonna do
this doc now then that other random dude
yeah Wade Robson is the one then the
other random do comes out and does it it
was like oh no I'm I got molested a
pregnant
here's the other thing here's the other
thing that Wade Robinson right
he had a years prior to saying that he's
my spy Michael Jackson suffers an
anxiety or panic attack because he was
going broke and his career wasn't what
he hoped it believed dated Britney
Spears [ __ ] then obviously hung
out with Michael Jackson
so there's to me now did Michael Jackson
touch kids probably think so right that
probably issue probably now but there's
also another and you know I'm not really
into conspiracies but there's a
conspiracy out there when Michael
Jackson got the Masters of all the
Beatles tapes and all his stuff and
cornered the market yeah well then all
these rumors started to fly around you
know I'm saying my question is this is
it possible that Michael Jackson because
of his lost youth just wanted to hang
out with children because this is just a
problem with you I gotta watch it um and
is there enough evidence to suggest that
actually what he did was have sex these
kids because how many kids were there
and would there wouldn't those kids
finally like if just two came forward
wouldn't there be more well there were
more but they all settled outside of
court okay they all settled outside of
court however a lot of these kids now
are adults and they didn't give their
consent mm-hmm so they could come out
now as adults right so in other words
you settle with my parents but now I'm
an adult and you know you should come
out or or again they might be you know
they might be you know just so we know
that Macaulay Culkin Corey Feldman all
these guys were hung out with him they
say nothing happened they say nothing
happened right so so it's interesting
because we know the child molesters do
like look at these priests
fifthly pray up they pray oh come on he
molested me too
I'm here so it's it's interesting so the
question is I know but there's just so
many it's very strange
I didn't see it here's the other thing
though is they they they raided his
house several times unannounced while he
was there with little boys they never
found anything during the raids but on
the contrary to that I don't know where
I stand on this to be honest you
probably touch okay send ahead gun to
the head touch my second touch kids okay
not had sex with them but touch them I
don't know bro I don't all of the above
all of the earth read a steep satin
attack this is max with it when I'm
locked in a hotel room with anyone for
more than a day yeah we busting nuts
yeah I mean did the whole thing's crazy
but I do with a girl I need to know who
was there it was it just he yeah woman
yeah but here's the thing you know who
did testify against him which is kind of
weird
his cleaner is made when I saw many of
times with little boys naked what yeah
oh she did yeah well I came out she went
yes you asked so I'm with little boys
many of times naked in a room like
multiple times with her maybe my [ __ ]
either it's very strange
here's the thing - so like you said it's
like why are you spending time with
these little boys like are you this
[ __ ] up that you need to spend time
with little kids because you're getting
H browsing you sued the [ __ ] out of
because you know they all they didn't
know they'd have the consent to do this
and there's a non-compete clause they
weren't allowed to release his stuff but
they thought this wouldn't be like dark
kelly thing and [ __ ] Michael Jackson
well he's dead right then and they want
money out of it so now they're kind of
screwed because not that many people
watch this you know that no I did it
wasn't that big of a hit really it's not
like dr. Kelly thing or Kelly's [ __ ]
he's speaking of our Kelly did you see
his interview sure didn't I don't have a
hard time I don't have a hard time you
know seeing this no oh [ __ ] chin we
don't we get kicked off YouTube did you
see it anyone see it it's not killing of
you know they sit down he starts crying
is this the camera here just the camera
who's why would I do that it makes no
sense but there's video or he goes why
you living in the past
well excuse me sir okay oh this doesn't
know I I well that's the real one up top
gin and that's it all those different
you're talking about there Gayle King
one yes
again how many women are there there he
is freaking out so I think the point
you're making is and correct me if I'm
wrong then you have never held anybody
against their will I don't need to think
why would I well I'm out stupid with
everything or Akeley with all I've been
through in my way lady pass to hold
somebody let alone four five six fifty
you say it how stupid I didn't say use
your common sense
don't forget the class forget how you
feel about me hate me if you want to
love me if you want but just use your
common sense how stupid would it be for
me to with my crazy passing what I've
been through
all right now I just think I need to be
a monster and hold girls against a real
chain them up in my basement and and
don't let them eat and don't let them
out unless they need some shoes down the
street from the Apple drop it don't quit
playing quit playing
Gayle King just on the dam hasn't talked
to him don't have relationship with the
kids doesn't nope never seen them what
not a dad they don't know that Kelly's
emotions remain draw there's real girls
out there missing it's real young girls
out there being abducted being raped
okay they really are on chains they
really do okay this is so hard to watch
any great
we have to have a conversation I know
how the whole time aren't you just
ranting at the camera go fund me okay
turn this off this is the no you ready
oh man that is not a good situation in
the grade oh boy that is that's that is
a disaster so here's the thing so then
they interview just to current
girlfriends now and they're defend him
like we we love him because the the
girlfriend's parents say he's
brainwashed them and they haven't heard
from their daughter in two years area
fifteen year old back in the day so so
these two girlfriends now though right
so the parents say that yet so the two
girlfriends the parents say they've
kidnapped him they brainwashed him so
Gayle Kings interview on the two of them
and how about our Kelly is in the wall
next to him and when they would say
something that like they're going down a
road he don't wanna he said he'd go she
was like it was so obvious he didn't
want them saying stuff she's sitting
there going aha how funny is that oh I
find it hilarious going to jail right oh
yeah a third video actually just came
out of what of him and a young girl
underage girls we're to the second one
it's like a sex tape third video third
video well oh no I am you just can't be
that guy on there lying there are no
tapes of the same fate that my temp
right and another sex Ava surfaced
Gloria offers repping the guy who claims
we have found turn over the cops Wow I'd
love to see that table are there tapes I
mean it says so there are actual tapes
of him cuz I remember back in the day
they said he was I'm gonna pee on it he
was talking about your fourteen-year-old
blah blah blah son you and he was peeing
on her right so she was 14 mm-hmm and I
don't I never understood how that all
went away and that he was fine I believe
it was because the girl in the video and
her parents want to cover it up and they
claim the
wasn't her okay yeah they came but you
don't put them after my understand notes
I am well it's also you know that's
really humiliating and you want your
daughter to have a life and you have no
money and you don't know how to protect
yourself and you're like let's just make
it go away and I'll you know you know I
mean like I'll just film here piss tapes
in the 90s man oh man he's a guy who
likes to own human beings not not have a
relationship with him well there it's
interesting cuz they know they're
predator so they say they groom him so
they said are Kelly start off by saying
you know he gets a girlfriend and then
bad he goes call me daddy right normal
standard [ __ ] we all like that give it
up yep give it up old man and so then
daddy that's fine and then I'll Kelly
goes cool in the bedroom call me daddy
thing cuz now just while we're out call
me daddy so you only refer to me as
daddy and their girls like a little
weird but you're buying me cool [ __ ]
sure daddy this is fun
I think it was yeah cool so you call me
daddy now now you can only leave the
house when daddy says oh now you have to
ask daddy when you got to go to when you
need to go to the bathroom now daddy
said you can't talk your parents now
daddy's gonna piss on you okay that's
how it goes so daddy wants to vicious
cycle ownership of your body in your
mind yeah here's some weird [ __ ] girls
is that this it's a call it's basically
a call that's it what's up quality
that's the cult leaders but his thing
instead of having power over like a
group and stuff you just wants to piss
on you and control your entire life yeah
yeah so again you're crazy oh you don't
think Kyle's caught those other cult
guys are pissing on people that ultimate
kind of device to move pee on someone
yeah that wouldn't be fun right it'd be
weird huh
why look I can't imagine like you ready
no I mean I'm gonna pee on you also I
can't control my stream can you I know a
girl I know I'm set my computer so she
drank her boyfriend's pee that's
dedication
do you have her number no but I said why
would you guys see cuz it was just hot
because he like he owned me and I wanted
to show him that he was my man
good job I kind of a job was she hot yes
oh very hot it's weird if they're really
Holub like damn links on now every like
no she's hideous like no she was hot I
remember I remember she she we were
talking about fetishes and well I don't
want her to be like him
no she just said my Lauren's drink my
pills like Goering all the time like I'd
be gross but what like once a year
drink your pee but no but I don't want
to be like don't pressure just like I
want her back just piss on me you just
piss on me just piss on me I knew a lady
of the eye by girl I I know a hooker who
would say put some glasses on I know a
lady used to have sex for money she was
there a personal trainer okay and she
used to uh and I sat down and had a very
can of talk with her weird okay she
would pay this guy he would get in a
bathtub and she wanted he wanted her
morning pee so she had to hold all he
wants that camel pissed the stored pee
over the night word pee over the night
that was uber yellow and she know he
would lie under and his mouth he'd be
trying to catch all he was nuts for it
weird yeah so nah like if you're gonna
do it you better have on some Ray Bans
or some oakley's cuz my piss is hard and
fast yeah you got a black your eye up
you got a big old horse bladder - yeah
you were taking a piss in a cup just
surprise you on which I ran tennis
cancer free balls
I felt the keep hands can't then I had
more left over ya know I've done a big
big goal oh yeah
[ __ ] toss in it do yep yep and I can't
control it if I get like got your piss
now like it what girls like piss on me
like girl it ain't gonna come out like
I'll scream like it's gonna shoot you
know we're going to the races and I mean
the horse-racing mmm I'm gonna laser
your face with this yeah I'm gonna laser
your face with ya dude this ain't a
drizzle is Hannah drizzle perfect storm
all right I gotta piss though now
talking about Kelly's you're not P let's
go yeah we're back back I pissed on
Brian just to try it out a laser beam
laser feel good don't laser you feel
good though bro you make sure he's a
good horse I hit the eyelid on a trip
down yeah
I had some brown off your tea so I've
got some PMI let's let me just get out
of there okay let's do some critter
vents sweet here's the first one
so first cousins from Utah drove all the
way to Colorado to get married because
in Utah they weren't able to because
they're under the age limit of 65
apparently it's law that if you are
first cousins you can get married in
Utah only if you're 65 or 55 years old
and can prove that you guys are
infertile Wow
apparently it's legal in Colorado
because because the reason is is because
when you know first cousins have kids
it's nice to bond with an under Jo if
you know what I mean
really inbred but also back in the day a
lot of people made their cousins cuz
you're kind of in a yeah but like you're
cool I know yeah yeah a lot of times
that's what you did you made your dozen
snack distance yeah yeah
so Colorado has a rule for over 65 can
do her the [ __ ] you want
no Colorado they allowed these 20 year
olds to get married we're you know sperg
Empire the Hapsburgs they would breed
back in the day you had royal blood and
you only bred with royal blood and God
decreed you as the king and anybody who
Bundy you you were a higher birth really
essentially so the Hapsburgs they just
kept interbreeding until the final error
had to be helped onto his horse he had
an underbody chin what's that say one
dead four wounded after shooting lower
downtown to ever click on that that
right now no idea March 10th
what's today they love it oh you plan
that my brother works every person is
dead for more in the hospital after a
shooting in downtown that's right it
happened near the intersection of 15th
and market and box 31 seven crew go is
live right there with the very latest
operation into this no 4 a.m. nothing
good happens if we ran yeah Matt police
still out here investigating more than
13 hours after this shooting happened
take a look at this you can see these
bullet holes labeled in the side of this
business here on Market Street tonight
police still searching for two suspects
after a shootout right here turns deadly
it's unfortunate that people will result
to this level of violence
off Market Street near Larimore square
police say a fight between two men broke
just after 4:00 a.m. that escalated into
a shooting it's possible if there was
more than one shooter or person who
discharged a guy does not look like a
French Bulldog shot and already dead
when police arrived the suspects in this
case flat we don't have good information
he does not look like a pug dog but
would not comment or a.m. bars close up
you know what I think less closing 12:30
they're all suck you did
damn Denver's getting weird huh wait go
back oh let me call a jackoff with his
feet he does totally sound like he's on
cash ish he's on fire chain first Vegas
eyebrows we appreciate that we do have
some video from our systems but we
always ask for the community's help and
we always pass he'll probably what's up
y'all say he's probably seen at dick in
Hispanic yeah he's been pissed on
doubling our efforts to efforts
technology in our city to address this
as well as [ __ ] right Denver you've
got to make up yeah dude what of it bro
come Adam tonight you keep pace and
asking anyone I'm proud of Denver's data
is that a hard day chief not that we
hold them accountable for these types of
crimes justice will be served
I'm proud of them what else you got
[Laughter]
justice is ours to pull as kids you you
can't understand you just so flustered
of course you go nuts yeah so a bus
driver seemed to have had been
intoxicated the hospital
my mom keep doing it does this stay what
she was under the influence of but the
kids didn't note that they were making
fun of her driving initially because she
was kind of swerving driving a little
odd they were [ __ ] on her driving
skills and she she makes a right turn a
little too quickly for the bus and the
kids start asking her to pull over she
gets agitated and says that she has half
a month to drop them off at the gas
station and make their parents pick them
up to wish the kids all agreed she got
angry pulled over gave the keys to the
bus to the employee who worked inside
the gas station didn't let the kids to
leave from the front door so they had to
go through the escape out vacuum of the
bus and their parents came and picked
them up I mean she lost her job of
course she basically told you to go [ __ ]
yourself
don't drop the kids off and I can't be
drunk driving with the kids and say go
[ __ ] yourself how old were these kids
they were about highschool girls so
they're roasting the [ __ ] out of her
come on loriann appeared a jeté tit
that's hilarious
carry on tough job so a billionaire
diamond trader died due to complications
during a penis enlargement procedure
Susan somebody I just talked to his
father
what yes well you know he's friends with
the girl's father sorry oh he was just
telling me the story he was like dude
okay
65 I wanted dude its dude it the rides
over I was gonna go for more churros
after the run Diamond traitor apparently
it was noted that he was very insecure
about his size he's a super small dick
in your billionaire that [ __ ] with you
yeah and apparently he used to look at
his bank account to make him feel better
when he was down which I bet he does
yeah a small dick he's like yeah
whatever bro yeah there's a billing in
there I feel all right they injected a
fluid during the procedure at the very
beginning and he had some complications
the whatever the liquid was it actually
started a heart attack and that's how he
died probably leave your dick alone
yeah here yeah well I'd say about that
well he knows diamonds I probably am
like this if you have a micro dick
there's no [ __ ] joke man
you know micro dick yeah kind of microbe
yeah if you're a billionaire money can't
buy happiness there you go course it
can't guys Worth's a billion dollars and
still struggle because he's a small dick
yes I'm sure he paid millions and
millions of girls millions of dollars to
[ __ ] and they're like he's serious right
now dear
probably well you know you know you're
not giving the girl pleasure when she's
like push harder you're almost inside of
me you know the girls sucking your dick
like it's a foot like G Deena ed on
mommy you know yeah note that no it's a
bummer dude what's with your milk dud
yeah but worth the billion I don't give
a [ __ ] dude I'd rather hook up with a
broke kid yeah said no hot girl ever
that's a bummer
well they don't get dick operations it's
embarrassing if yours kids yeah how'd
your dad die oh good question had a
micro dick and died in the procedure if
I'm p.m. can if you have a billion
dollars can you not pay the press rate
oh my dad died in a great white accident
yeah
getting by shark let's celebrate him my
little wiener what else you yet do you
think it'd be harder for him to have
kids since he has a smaller dick no I
have two kids the seam is still bust out
of there
you know I'm good for each other cuz if
it like barely interests good question
my guess is some women left him because
his dick was small he knew it now I get
my cat saying though because like let's
say you got long John Dixie ever right
because it you know that dicks just
pumping the semen in there yeah it's a
small one it's not making us far so the
swimmers have to go farther
it's like pumping gas but like the
nozzle isn't quite in there's really no
sense that's a good question even think
about it
nothing I've ever had to think about
yeah there's a back Pig digs vertex yeah
so chin is it a problem [ __ ] what else
we got
so a real estate developer recently just
finished his terrible divorce with his
ex-wife and what he did was he put a
photo of himself and his new wife on the
apartment building that his ex-wife was
supposed to live was she young and hot
younger because he's 88 I believe his
wife was also around that agent dude why
not I mean yeah yeah the biggest ego in
the world to do this but oh why hey what
but if you're 85 right like you're not
much long like [ __ ] it how much is it
few million yeah plus my new hos face on
the building that's kind of mean it's
kind of weird
yeah but she's gonna make out whoever
that woman is make out with him you know
it is we're thinking well it's a hell of
a way to do it what else yet Jesse
Smollett indicted on 16 counts felony
counts for every time you told a lie
he's [ __ ] yeah yeah game over dude
question is how much what will he do
time I doubt it
I'll probably get you the room right you
don't your careers ruined let's just do
your work good with that yeah they're
going okay he might have to pay for all
that investigation though there's money
that Daddy yes well yeah I think he's
being like 2 million year off Empire
Hotel sister to hit me up with her you
know what else we got her name from back
to the art Kelly thing real quick his ex
lawyer said that he would take anti
libido shots to suppress his sexual
urges dick game on a thousand new I take
pills to calm your boner down yeah
urges with girls or just sex in general
sex in general Danny I'm gonna get ya
urges like for a while for a period Wow
so I here's a he's addicted to sex sex
that one every guy about sex says every
guy ever
damn see how bad you got if you gotta
take pills dude yeah so you don't fight
I was so gross no I like how the lawyers
like I'll tell you a secret I don't go
to a doctor yet just libido killing
shots that's why I didn't get arrested
for anything else okay thanks a lot mr.
lawyer I'm sure that lawyer is great too
I'm sure that lawyer is a great guy
alrighty another guy who can't control
his sexual urges is this guy Kellen
Winslow jr. the football player yes you
said so good
was he thought I'll just play this for
cuz it's better for you guys to hear
this story we want to let you know
before we get to this next story that
the details are certainly not
appropriate for children there is a
disturbing twist in the case against
Kellen Winslow jr. the ex-football star
is already facing charges of kidnap and
rape well his attorneys trying to get
several of those charges dropped today
but now there are new accusations of
lewd conduct NBC 7's arnie anita's at
the sheriff's department with this
update on what's going on now RT
Catherine in Monaco cannot Kellen
Winslow jr. was free on bond but now he
has been ordered back to jail without
bail because while his attorneys were
trying to get some of those previous
charges dropped he now stands accused in
a new case for allegedly committing lewd
acts on a 77 year old woman take a look
at some new video of Winslow jr. in
court today he's scheduled to go to
trial next month he's having charges
Winslow has pleaded not guilty your
buddy
he's accused of kidnapping and raping
two transgender women in Encinitas he
has some serious problems successful in
getting one of the kidnapping counts
dropped the judge said there was
insufficient evidence on that count oh
my all of the other counts will stand
Winslow is also accused of exposing
himself to another woman in front of her
Encinitas home and in yet another case
he's facing rape allegations from 2003
when the victim was 17 years old so
while all pounds they just stand there
guiding Winslow finds himself in trouble
with the law again he has now been
charged with four misdemeanor counts
that include two lewd acts in front of a
seven
seven-year-old woman inside a Carlsbad
gym and this Wow he's in California
he reached out and he touched her on the
arm she pulled her arm back he touched
her on the with his foot on her foot and
she reported what happened to her
husband they reported it to the gym and
ultimately to law enforcement
oh Jesus that's not hot tub bump that we
got today that's right that's that's
that's not a lewd I mean he's a bad guy
and he was touching himself while he's
doing that to her he was touching
himself up where's jack jack pretty bad
he's a terrible person
hell of a football player man was he Oh
God when you see a Miami
really good player his dad televisions
Oh was a stud
tight end big boy stud man well I didn't
know he's such a terrible person Wow
kidnapping trick those are crazier Jesse
it's 77 year old woman that is just
ridiculous underage girl - he's trying
to yep between 17 and 77 yeah that's I
don't discriminate he just wants to say
no yeah he's trying to bust that nut
dangerous to be a woman I'll tell you
that much [ __ ]
all right yeah yeah a woman in Arizona
this head of zoo she try to climb past
the barrier she did and try to take a
selfie and of course the Jaguar attack
this is this the same guy who I [ __ ]
the camper alone she was crying and yeah
that's what you did Duncan Paige crying
she came back and apologized like a
Jaguar though you know that yeah he
might was like my bad that's my fault I
kept trying to get a really good selfie
that Jaguar she's scared do you see the
gash on her arm she got [ __ ] up look
Jaguar [ __ ] yeah but also this is
Jaguars doing Jaguar [ __ ] of courts and
attack the lady and they got really
close to the cage don't say jagwire just
a Jaguar
I say yeah glare Jaguar yeah what
yahuwah
that's how you get you dumb [ __ ] yeah
I'm great leave the animal you want see
you're crying yeah I want to see her she
Gonzales hmm
tonight this is what the gas is bad
Jaguar at an Arizona zoo is recovering
you're her yelling in pain as by Sting
no she's just she's having a panic
attack it's distracting the animal with
a water bottle look at its grip
officials it's not bad if world zoo near
Phoenix City got clocked over a barrier
to take a selfie near the Jaguars
enclosure Saturday the large cat
reaching through the fence digging its
claws into her arm a similar incident is
not the same Jaguar just last year the
zoo's director stressing the Jaguar will
not be euthanized because neither attack
was the animal shocked now it's not
observed the barrier they're there for a
good reason we try to keep everyone safe
this comes two months after a lion at a
Wildlife Sanctuary in North Carolina
mauled an intern to death and this close
call it a zoo in Florida this child
injured after falling into a rhino
exhibit and back to the attack this
weekend a zoo spokesperson says that
woman who was injured actually went back
today to apologize admitting she was
wrong to cross that barrier tom
at least she apologized all good just
don't do stupid things like that that
that woman who [ __ ] did also selfie
with jaguar all right what do you do
with that man and if I know Jaguars will
come right at you most animals well in
those cages Jaguar what else you got
wiser okay let's see how about this one
just Paige has that on Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Edition
yeah she looked good start talking real
quick those are I didn't know she was
working with that kind of a rack
who knew Oh Frank
this whole crew some and then there's
more those look very real to me this is
like the best shot I think yes she's
gorgeous
she's yeah I respected happy
International Women's Day everybody so
those are new I thought those were real
are you sure I just shut up for a second
without I don't believe that those are
fake
I believe yeah I don't know one time
Matt keep going chin I think that's
pretty much because it's so obvious and
those go bit months ago does not look
fake yeah my I'm the show when I had Ron
she was the I did do that was it was the
page show though smoke show me I have
yeah rest yeah definitely smoke show
yeah alright there's this a random dude
came out and pushed a soccer player in
the face during the game I saw this he
kind of misses though kind of but it
looked like he hit him with his forearm
good enough to hurt him we're security
that's a thing that's a huge problem in
the ninth minutes a fan run onto the
pitch salted Aston Villa's Jack greenish
these are images here's what's great
together they its socked in the face hit
the game-winning goal though yeah the
only gold scored and say you should get
us that guy should get us [ __ ]
[Applause]
there is
um Brittany Shattuck Jack realest
realest
there you go boom nice dude tits and
soccer that's what we do Brock are my
favorite things titties and soccer and
people Yin pissed on did it dude how
much would it cost for me to piss on you
for reals
that's what I might wear would you pay
on your face on my face and your still I
get to wear on your stupid ear don't do
I get to wear goggles and do I know you
can cover your eyes though with your
hands okay how much just to pee on me I
wouldn't want to I feel bad but not to
[ __ ] up for a second I'm working out a
deal here how much give me uh like
honestly it's a lot of money you do ver
hondo I can film it hundred thousand
dollars I might do that just to
advertise my special coming up yeah I
don't give a finally I'll hold it we
hold a sign says shop Showtime so just a
little pee on me yeah I'll give it to
charity while I go viral it's great
money if it did are Kelly's victims okay
well no I won't keep it well alright
well we'll figure it out I'm that's
Lauren I thought I will entertain this
idea okay all right all right I don't
think that's it man we can't I covered
that yeah
how much have me [ __ ] no no hold on Oh
relax relax for a second you can't
[ __ ] panic you lie down you're naked
let me finish you open your butt oh I
[ __ ] in the crack there's gotta be a
number this is the sky well how much
we're just um up how much no I won't do
it you'd never do it for a million
dollar go for a million dollars I won't
do it you wouldn't let me drop a deuce
in the crack of your rump
yeah that's disgusting you're such a
[ __ ] you take it for a million dollars
you [ __ ] good man like you're saying
that now then film it I don't know man
[ __ ] it's a million dollars you
little [ __ ] you wouldn't have a little
somebody else you wouldn't have your
buddy [ __ ] in your bow man I'm trying
where that comes out of the help nope
now you're being a prude now you want to
talk like well these others
number no eyebrows no number I'd and you
have to smile 20 million 20 million 20
minutes you 20 million tap my shoes
ain't you piss in your mouth no I didn't
say mouth good hard to go I know you're
gay the second time I didn't say mouth
of $25,000 I'll do it
25 bucks I'm 25 listen I think so you
wouldn't you wouldn't peel the piece and
let me go from no dude I promise it was
she's such a [ __ ] friend I really I
know I am I will figure higher right
about where you gonna be I be I'm at the
I think we only have like 70 tickets
left at the make-a-wish Foundation for
cobs this Thursday and then I got Kansas
City improv the 22nd and 23rd of March
at Philadelphia have you been to Kansas
City before yes
great great town Philadelphia March 28th
29th 30th come see me then I got Calgary
Yuk Yuk's yep Calgary April 4 5 & 6
but listen get your tickets and my
special drafts to my yes get it Apes
pick it up
rent it buy it wherever you want
it's available all over I to and
everywhere yeah drops tomorrow yes sir
boom this Friday Saturday my first time
Miami Miami improv Late Show at it on
Friday
so get your cheeks now fried this Friday
and Saturday Miami improv next week I'm
in Milwaukee Turner Hall theater
Milwaukee one show Friday one show
Saturday and then the end of the month
I'm in Washington DC DC improv March
28th through the 30th taste now t fat K
hmm is that it pissed boy that's it this
is a funny kid brow